was another not great dance of yours
i was not super impressed
how are you feeling are you feeling
still that frustration are you still
feeling like it's personal no i'm kind
of over it i agree i think we just have
to like move
forward and onward you need to give us
more
have you talked to carrie anne have you
had anything like that
no i think it's at this point i just
think it's
it's her being a judge she's a tough
judge i think she's just
maybe holding me to a higher standard
tonight caitlyn and artem will get
toxic in their attempt to impress the
judges
[Music]
it's icon week did you pick britney
arden's like oh yes she did
yes i did what britney are you going to
be
we're getting a naked bodysuit in the
rhinestone trip
[Music]
what does jason think about this how
exciting for him
probably like bring home the costume
this mirror ball is weeks away how bad
do we want this
when i go to sleep i pretend that
there's confetti falling on me and i
smell it
and i go it's gonna happen